resuelve usando el método de eliminación
la suma de dos números es 70 y su
diferencia es 24 cuáles son esos números
la suma de dos números es 70 esto como
se expresa en matemáticas
bueno pues voy a agarrar los números x
james los voy a sumar y la suma de estos
dos le tienen que dar 70 así de fácil
obtengo mi primera ecuación ahora dice
que su diferencia es 24 así que x menor
james esto tiene que ser 24 y ojo aquí
estoy asumiendo que x es el número más
grande x es el número más grande de
estos dos muy bien y después dicen que
resolvamos este sistema de ecuaciones
por el método de eliminación por lo
tanto lo que voy a hacer es sumar estas
dos ecuaciones para que se cancele una
de estas dos variables ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que puedo
aplicar este método porque estoy sumando
24 de ambos lados de la ecuación del
lado derecho de sumando 24 y de la
izquierda también porque yo sé que x
menos james es exactamente igual a 24
eso lo que me dice la otra ecuación así
que vamos a hacerlo más bien menos ya se
cancelan x mas x es 12
2x es lo mismo que 70 + 24 70 + 24 es lo
mismo que 94 por lo tanto obtengo la
ecuación 2x igual a 94 y fíjate qué
importante es esto porque lo que estoy
encontrando es una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita y como lo dice
eliminando la jem sumando estas dos
ecuaciones recuerda que lo que estoy
haciendo realmente es sumando 24 de
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
derecho es obvio que estoy sumando 24 y
tales medidas oye pero del lado
izquierdo nuestras sumando 24 estoy
sumando x menos yen sin embargo la
segunda ecuación lo que me dice es
exactamente eso que x menos james es
igual a 24 por lo tanto estoy sumando 24
de ambos lados de la ecuación solamente
que con nombres distintos y genial
porque al sumar estas dos ecuaciones
obtengo que 2x es igual a 94 o si
dividido entre 2 ambos lados de la
ecuación voy a obtener que x es igual a
94 entre 2 lo cual es 47 ya tengo el
valor para x x vale 47 ahora voy a
sustituir este valor en la primera
ecuación para obtener el valor de bien
es decir que 47 más siempre es igual a
70 y si yo quito 47 de ambos lados de la
ecuación esto
y voy a tener que james es igual a 70
menos 47 lo cual es a 70 menos 47 23
perfecto ya tengo la solución de este
sistema de ecuaciones x igual a 47 igual
a 23 cumplen las dos ecuaciones porque
su suma es 70 y por otra parte 47 menos
23 es lo mismo que 24 por lo tanto se
cumplen ambas ecuaciones